what is going on everybody welcome to
part 8 of the high torch tutorials in
this video what we're gonna be talking
about is model analysis or I guess the
basic model analysis so the topic of
figuring out how a model works and why
and how good it is is a huge research
question but for the most part for most
of the tasks that you're gonna do at
least for me personally I would say
these two metrics or really four metrics
account for 99 percent of the time or
account for what I need 99 percent of
the time and that is the in and out of
sample accuracy and loss so in sample
accuracy in sample loss out of sample
accuracy out of sample loss with those
four values tract and trended over time
you can pretty well tell at least for
our purposes what we're after is either
two things how long should we train a
model for so at what point should we
stop training and hey this is all we're
going to get from this model as well as
what model is better so how do we
determine like if we want to compare two
models trying to solve the same task
which one is better than the other one
so that's what we're going to get into
today so in order to do that basically
all the code is the same as it's been up
to this point the only thing I've done
is I've gotten rid of our training test
function I'm gonna end up kind of
remaking those here and the reason why I
want to do that is before you know the
this whole series at anytime we're doing
something complicated like deep learning
my job as a teacher is to simplify
simplify simplify but at some point we
start violating certain rules like don't
repeat yourself so really what we want
is some sort of function that accepts
data that we pass and returns outputs
right and also if necessary calculates
gradient and loss and all that so the
first thing I want to do is actually
create a forward pass function because
really what we want to do is while we
are training we also want to do tests we
don't want to just do a test at the very
end
and then also we don't necessarily even
want to just do tests like every epoch
we we'd like to do pretty granular
testing we don't necessarily want to do
a test every step or for every batch but
we if we want to we'd like the ability
to so anyways the first thing I want to
do is make a new function and I'm gonna
call this forward pass I can't think of
a better name for it right now so I'm
gonna go with that obviously Pass is
taken fit is not quite accurate because
we're not going to use this just to fit
we're gonna use this to also test so not
fit so anyway mmm this is gonna take X's
Y's and then it'll have a train flag
that we're gonna default to false so
when we pass data through here by
default we will not update weights we'd
rather that be the case because again it
is so easy to cheat with neural networks
you know unintentionally and so if you
set the default to be true you might
forget and it's gonna train on your
validation data no good you might not
realize that's happening whereas if you
forget to set train equals true your
models not gonna learn and you're gonna
you're gonna find out really quickly
something's wrong so anyway little stuff
like that it's small as it is it really
will make a difference you will make
you'll make so many mistakes especially
with PI torch like PI torch is really
cool I think it's great for learning and
it's really cool to do custom things
with PI torch and I'm still kind of
undecided on which I like better like PI
torch or tensor flow with chaos but it
reminds me of working with raw tensor
flow in the sense that you can make a
lot of mistakes and get lost very fast
so anyway little stuff like that you've
got to always be thinking about
so anyway moving on if train is true
we're gonna go ahead and net zero grad
so we'll zero the gradients
I'm not going to handle the torch with
was it torch no grad or whatever whoa I
think we'll try to call that I think we
can get away with just calling it before
this function that way we don't need to
you because otherwise we'd be hard but
anyway moving on we're gonna say outputs
equals net X so we'll just pass what
that X is and then regardless of whether
this is an in-sample or out-of-sample
either way we want to be calculating
accuracy because we do want both in and
out of sample accuracy because one of
the main things is comparing the two
most of the time you're in sample
accuracy will be greater than your
out-of-sample accuracy there are going
to be times where you usually you've
messed up somehow where your
out-of-sample accuracy could in theory
if you higher than your in sample
accuracy but you that's a major red flag
so outputs net X okay so what we need to
do is first we want to know how how
accurate were so basically we want to
compare Y and outputs and in any case
where the arguments of why is the Arg
max of output right as we iterate over
this because this will be a batch of
data so basically it's how many Arg
maxes are identical to each other and
that would be how much you got right so
whether this is an out-of-sample test or
an in-sample test doesn't really matter
we want to know how many are identical
so we're going to say matches equals and
we're going to say the torch Arg max I
and then we're going to assert that it's
equal to the torch Arg max of j4 I comma
J in zip and we're going to zip together
outputs and Y so I'm assuming people at
this point are pretty familiar with
Python but this is just a nice little
tight list comprehension but for IJ and
zip we're just you know combining them
together outputs and why we're just
comparing the Arg max of both of those
vectors and as long as those are the
same this will be true if they're not
the same it will be false so then all we
want to do is we want to count how many
true and how many falls so we're gonna
say accuracy or ACK accuracy equals
matches count and we want to count how
many throughs do we have and then we'll
just divided by the Len maybe hmm
the Len of matches so how many true
matches over the length of matches so
this will give us a percentage accuracy
then we're going to compute the loss and
that's going to be loss equals loss
function four outputs why and I do
believe we should have the loss function
[Music]
does oom buy it maybe yes there is okay
cool so we already have that defined so
okay so we've computed the loss and then
finally again we're gonna ask one more
time
if train we want to lost on backward
we've just basically do our back
propagation and then optimizer dot step
cool and then we will return the
accuracy and loss so now we've got this
forward pass function and this we're
going to use this both for training and
testing purposes so for example we can
all we can create a test function now we
can say how much do we want to test and
so we'll just say for now we'll just
default to 32 X y equals test X up to
the size and then test y slice that size
sorry I'm thinking about I'm still
trying to decide on a decent way to get
a random slice and part of me is
thinking that one way I could do it I
just thought of a way I could get a
random slice I've been trying to
determine how to get a random slice
because what I would normally want to do
is normally I would just zip these two
things together convert it to a list
because you can't shuffle the zip object
and then slice it and then put it back
out but then I was getting all kinds of
torch and tensor issues doing that it
was super messy but now just now
unfortunately I hate when this happens
because then I want to try it live and
it's usually a mistake to try things
live but
what if we could say random let's say a
random start point is equal to I think
we have numpy already here numpy so what
if we just said NP is oh shoot I can't
remember now - is NP R and oh I could
actually do this on a different cell let
me just pop down a cell here real quick
import numpy as n P and P dot random dot
random okay so that's gonna be a random
number between 0 and 1 really what I
want is a R and range random dot R and
range I don't think yeah you don't you
don't do that for me huh
Oh is there a R and range numpy inter
range random sampling numpy dot random
dot R and int can i specify and int
takes at least how about randon to a
hundred can you do that okay so it goes
from zero to a hundred it looks like
okay so what I'm thinking we could do is
we could take size so if like size
equals 32 we could say Rand int and then
we know we know what the Len of test X
is so it should be anything from 0 to
the Len of test X minus jerk don't do
that to me sighs cool I'm kind of proud
of that that'll work
there's probably better away than this
but hey check it out so then so now what
we can do is that so we get a random
start and now instead what we'll do is
we'll slice random start - random start
plus size so this just always leaves
room for whatever that sizes and then
we slice from that random size to size
and now now we should get a random slice
it's not a random it would just be a
slice starting at a random point so it's
not gonna be like shuffled or anything
like that but that'll be good that'll
give us a better distribution of
validation over time so cool we're gonna
go with that hope that works
okay so Val ak and then Val loss will be
equal to forward underscore pass and XY
so yeah we'll pass X Y and train will be
false correct we've defined yes okay so
oh and then we also need to view this so
dot view is a negative one one fifty
fifty and then X dot view and then dot
to the device device and then we need to
do y dot two device why not - device one
option we do have twos we could actually
take in any X Y and then put it to the
device in the forward pass I think that
might make things look a little better
but and then we wouldn't have to code
the two device nonsense every single
freaking time I'm gonna I'm gonna carry
on we I've already made too many too
much change I can't wait to see if that
works okay so we've got Val AK fell off
and then we need to return Val ACK Val
loss and okay I think we've got a valid
test here let's go ahead and run one
real quick Val ACK Val loss equals test
size equals thirty-two we'll go with
that that's fine and then print now at
Val loss also oh I'm gonna make one more
change I think random start so
right here I think with torch dot no
grad do that I think we can get away
with calculating the gradient if I
remember this video is probably gonna be
really long I apologize
although anybody's still at this you're
probably interested in this topic so
fine I think that'll be good enough so
we're not wasting time calculating the
gradients we definitely don't want to
calculate the gradient or do hmm
actually I don't think we can do that
we'd have to calculate the gradient so
we can know I don't hmm we'll run this
way let's run this really quickly okay
so so we get the validation accuracy is
56 and then our loss is 0.24 that should
be good enough so cool all right let's
run that one more time Wow
and I that makes sense that it's varying
because we're taking a random slice so
that's kind of exciting and then
hopefully as things train we'll get a
little more consistent validation
accuracy so cuz I bet if we did like a
thousand although is that kind of batch
a thousand my GPU can probably handle it
though so yeah if we do a very large
batch you see it does trend towards
fifty percent okay so moving along we're
ready to actually start the training
loop so we're going to basically in the
train loop we're going to just call
tests as frequently as we want now
there's a couple things we're going to
think about here is in our train loop
basically we want to track basically
want to train the model but as we train
the model we also want to track how is
the in-sample validation the in-sample
accuracy and loss comparing to
out-of-sample accuracy and loss so we
want to be logging that information and
then we'd like to visualize it like you
can you could just output it to a
console and look at it but it's pretty
useful it's like visualize
it on a charts like a graph now I know
people if I don't bring this up people
are gonna be like what about and that is
tensor board which is the visualization
module that comes with tensor flow but
you can install tensor board and then
apparently you can use something called
tensor board x with PI torch and that
should allow you to use sensor board I
don't know what I do know is what I use
tensor board for is to just graph some
scalars ok that's basically it so I'm a
little confused why anybody is gonna go
way out of their way to use tensor board
when you can just graph it in matplotlib
so again 99% of what I'm doing with
visualizing you know and analyzing a
model is I'm graphing the the accuracies
and losses and actually what I'd really
like to be able to do is graph them on
the same graph if we'd like tensor board
I can't even do a basic thing like that
without seriously customizing tensor
board it's gonna take more code it's
gonna take more understanding of like
tensor board and stuff like that
whereas with matplotlib like I can have
any graph on Y if I want to graph some
scalars cool if I want to graph some bar
charts cool
also it's pi torch you don't have to use
matplotlib you could use plotly or like
- you could make your own tensor board
you could make you could go with like pi
gout you do anything you graph with some
other JavaScript falling library I think
the whole reason anyone's gonna use pine
torches for custom stuff so it just
seems wrong to use tensor board it's not
I mean well I use tensor board with
tensor flow because everything's the
codes already all done for us but what I
don't understand is why someone would
use PI torch and then like basically
port PI torch to tensor board I'm just
not I'm just not on board with that I
know some people might want that just
understand that tensor board X is
probably where you should start looking
ok so ok so that's what we're gonna do
so in order to do that we need a little
silly log file so to have a log file
first we're gonna want to save the model
name to the log file so we know what
we're graphing so fur model name
generally I would give it a nice name of
something to do with the the type of
model you're working with so is it a
three-layer 64 feature per layer comm
net you know stuff like that I would try
to make a useful name for now I'm just
gonna say model - and then we'll go with
int time time so I've always no matter
what I name the model I've always
appended time time to my model names
just because eventually you're gonna
chain something you're gonna forget to
change your model name and what they're
using intents are bored or what we're
doing here
your data is gonna run over each other
because you're using the same name and
you're really gonna kick yourself for it
whereas if you just do this every time
you run the model or make a new model
it's gonna have a new time so you're
welcome that will save you it has saved
me so many times so now we're going to
say his net equals and we're just gonna
start with a new one so net dot - device
and then we will redefine our optimizer
and loss function come down here cool
now let's go ahead and print model name
just so we see it to know what we're
doing and then now we're going to define
a train motion
okay so what do we need here first of
all we need a batch size go with
whatever you think can fit on your GPU
I'm gonna go with 100 so it goes
relatively decently fast if the you're
getting a memory error go with like 16
or 8 or whatever it takes 100 for me
EEP ox he pops I'm gonna go with 8 just
some number to go with something yup
generally somewhere between 1 and 10 EEP
oxes is probably enough but it really
will depend on what kind of task you're
actually doing and then same thing -
like if you're doing like transfer
learning which we haven't talked about
yet at some point we'll probably talk
about transfer learning you know might
even just be one epoch or
two epochs max but for the most part one
epoch is probably too few unless you
have just a massive data set which you
probably don't but at some point you
might so anyway all right now we're
gonna create a simple log file so I'm
just gonna say with open and I'm gonna
call this model dot log with the
intention to append as F what do we want
to do so for epoch in range epochs and I
let's go with five for range in epoch in
range epochs okay what do we want to do
well we want to start iterating over our
batches so the way that we've done that
is for I in TQ diem of range starting at
0 ending at the Len of train X taking
steps the size of our batch what do we
want to do well we want to slice our
data so batch x equals Train X and the
slice will be I 2 I plus the batch size
dot view as a negative 1 150 50 and then
we're gonna send that to our device dare
I copy and pasta this I shouldn't I'll
just write it okay too many things have
changed too many places to mess up so
batch Y is going to be equal to Train
why i to i plus batch size i did test
sizing it okay and then we will send
this as well dot to device okay so now
we can cap now that we've got x and y
we're ready to do a forward pass so what
we're gonna say is AK and loss is equal
to forward pass for batch x batch why
and don't forget your train flag train
equals true
okay so now that we've done that our
forward pass handles all of the training
for us so we actually are done with the
training stuff so now that we've got all
that code up there this is actually
pretty quick to write what is next well
we would like to start logging data so
the next thing we could do is do a test
so for example Val ACK Val loss is equal
to another forward pass of sighs
whatever thank you 132 whatever your
current batch size but here's the
problem so if you do that batch size
that means every single step you take
your you're almost like double your
training time because you're feeding
through twice as much data so I would
propose that either one you could go
with a smaller size and do it every step
but that's not really gonna be very
reliable like you've seen already how
variable a small size can be so I'd
rather go with a larger size but do it
not every step there's probably there
really no reason to do it every step but
you know in this for loop do I want to
do it for every I know but do I want to
do it as infrequently as every epoch no
so what can we do well we could say for
I modulo and then however many steps
that you want to do it so let's say
every 50 steps we want to calculate this
so we can say I modulo 50 double equals
zero and then not 4 it should be if I
don't know why I wrote for there but if
I modulo 50 equals zero so this will be
every every 50 steps this will be true
so so then so so now every 50 steps will
calculate Val accuracy validation loss
and then what we want to do is actually
save it to that file so the way that
we're gonna do that is we're gonna say F
dot write and then we're gonna write a
really long F string so we're going to
start with model name this will be a
nice little CSV file for us so we'll
start with model name comma and then
we're going to go with
round and then we're gonna round time
dot top time got time to three decimals
I mean it's just kind of depends on how
quickly you're doing these steps and if
anything actually we could probably do
three steps quicker than a second I
think so yeah well just that's fine that
should be fine
so okay shoot this is gonna get messy
we're gonna hit so many errors probably
okay now what we want to do is we want
to round the floats of the accuracy to
two decimal places and then we're going
to take this copy-pasta round loss so
accuracy out to two decimal places makes
sense I think lost we'd like a little
more granularity so I'm going to say two
four why are we converting to float by
the way uh so I think with accuracy
accuracy is pride just a Python value
actually loss however is going to be
where the heck are you here this is
gonna return a tensor so we want to get
that into not being a tensor anymore so
we're just gonna say float
there's probably there might be a more
efficient way to do that if you know a
better way let me know down below and we
probably don't even need to run I don't
think this actually has to be converted
to a float we can tinker with that later
for an out what I'm gonna do is take
this copy-paste and AK loss this will be
Val underscore AK and this will be Val
underscore loss also I'm gonna make my
text a little bigger I just realized
it's pretty small it's increased code
font size in case you can't see
something you can always go to the tech
space over in this tutorial there are
links in the description to that kind of
stuff every single time if it's not
there
remind me I'll put it there okay so this
is that whole line that we're gonna
write
and then don't forget a new line
otherwise we're gonna be so sad okay so
I think we're good so now that we've
done that we can say we can run train
and let's see how many errors we've hit
that's disgusting
forward pass got an unexpected Oh
um we didn't want for her pass we want
this to be test I hope that doesn't
sometimes if you hit an error it screws
up it's probably gonna do it I regret
everything it screws up the TQ DM oh we
got it nice cool okay so we are off uh
looks like epochs are gonna take about
25 seconds as opposed to I forget what
they were before they were they like
eight well there were eight seconds I
think on the the Linode GP you actually
haven't done it on this GPU so I can't
really tell you how much it's changed
anything but anyway okay so how many
epochs did we pick five okay so we're
gonna run five epochs and then this is
the model name that we're going with so
now what I want to do is actually graph
this and the way that we are going to
I'm trying to decide I don't think I
really want to graph it and Jupiter
notebook I think it would make more
sense to graph this in a sublime text
walk yes that looks ugly yeah you see
that too why is it so gross
go away and I want to do that so the
actual graph pops up and we can be
interactive with our graph cool the
other thing is I want to pull in before
I forget I want to bring in where are
you
let me do I'm gonna copy another model
log because I'm I've got one that I ran
for many epochs that
show you guys because I don't want to
run 30 epochs on video that would be
crazy cool okay so I paste copy that so
we don't have to wait what 15 minutes
basically to run 30 bucks okay so we are
creating that data so if we come over to
a model log here right click that open
with sublime we get this so as you can
see here you've got your all ready for
cut what order we did things and what
was it accuracy loss validation accuracy
validation loss so this will be
validation accuracy here so as you can
see it starts pretty bad as we continue
along though you can see your validation
accuracy is already up to 70% and it's
doing pretty good but you can see even
just looking at it these are slowly
starting to diverge pretty significantly
but it is hard it's easy to cherry-pick
like obviously it looks like oh yeah
they're back together again so it is
hard to see so now we want to do is
graph from this file there's a million
ways we graph from this file one of the
easier ways honestly would be to use
pandas I think we're just gonna I think
we're just gonna read and separate the
file though because I don't want to get
into pandas I don't want to confuse
anybody with pandas but honestly I would
use pandas
if I wasn't making a tutorial out of it
so anyway carrying on though so now what
we want to do is graph that so we're
gonna say import import matplotlib pipe
lots as pulse TLT don't do that to me
and then from Matt plot lib we're going
to import style and style die use we're
gonna use GG plot now we want to do is
we want to grab the model name and we're
if you're still in your notebook you
could just say equals caps model name in
our case this was the model name
yay for printing it out so I'll just do
that
so next once we have that we can just
make a little function or something
define create AK loss graph and then
we'll just pass the model name here and
then we're going to say the contents is
equal to the open of model dot log to
read and then we're gonna say dot read
dot splits by newline cool so it gives
us our contents then I'm just going to
say x is a list accuracies is list
losses is list Val X is going to be a
list Val losses is going to be
eventually one day when it grows up a
list so now we're going to do is just
iterate over our contents here so we're
gonna say for C in contents if a model
name in C again you might have multiple
model names in this log and we want a
very specific model not all of them so
we don't want to make that check if
model name in see what do we want to do
we're going to say the name the model
name and then time stamp that was that
unix time ACK loss Val ACK Val loss the
other thing we should have probably
added was epoch I'll put that in the
text base I don't feel like going back
for that equals C dot split it would
just be useful to know at what point did
we epoch because usually it's gonna be
at the epochs point where well one you
kind of want to know at what Epoque am i
at what epoch did things start to go bad
because you're gonna stop usually at us
but at an epoch but sometimes you'll
stop at number of steps actually two so
anyway it would be useful to know both
step count and epoch possibly
but you can also figure it out from the
graph so whatever okay so we've got our
data and then all we want to do now is
we're just going to say x dots pens
float timestamp don't forget to convert
everything to a float because right now
it's all a string form of x and then
basically we're just going to go x
accuracies losses Valek Val loss so x
accuracies losses Val ax Val losses and
then we append x timestamp accuracies ak
losses loss Val ACK and finally valve
loss exciting stuff hanging stuff okay
and then we're going to graph now for
people who are truly novices with
matplotlib you can go to Python
programming dot net go to data analysis
and go to data visualization there is
tons of customization that you can do
with matplotlib for example let's just
click on this one this one might show a
relatively complicated looking nope
that's a pretty basic looking graph
custom fills share XY custom legends
maybe this is the best one right so you
can make very complicated custom graphs
with matplotlib it doesn't have to be
super ugly it doesn't have to be super
beautiful but there's all kinds of crazy
stuff that you can do like this is price
and volume so this has like a multiple
y-axis you can also you can in this case
we've hidden the other axes you can also
plot multiple things on the same graph
you can do all kinds of custom fills and
blah blah blah blah okay matplotlib
really truly can have everything you
need but if you need to learn more about
how we're doing matplotlib if something
I say in the next few moments doesn't
make sense to you there is an entire
series here for you
I guess I could just leave this here I'm
just going to minimize it though okay so
we've got all of these you know these
lists here that we can graph time will
be our x axes and then we want to graph
the accuracies losses Val axe fat loss
[Music]
so what we're gonna say is fig equals
peel t dot figure this is just so we can
have multiple figures on you know if you
just wanted to graph like one thing you
really can just say
PLT dots plot and we could plot x
accuracies and then do a peel t dot show
and that should work oh we didn't call
this like cool let's try that one more
time
cool so now you can see how act in
sample accuracy has improved over time
but alone that's relatively worthless
other than seeing that wow it's actually
trending upwards well I'll be didn't
expect it okay so so it can be that
simple but I actually want multiple
graphs so I have to get a little more
fancy than that so first we define the
figure and then now we're gonna define a
couple of axes each axes is a graph you
can think of it that way peel T dot sub
plot to grid we are going to be working
on a two by one grid and so I'm gonna do
the same thing
define axes dos and it's a two by one
grid this one will start at the zero
zero mark this one hey buddy there we go
this one will start at the one zero mark
but fall so we want to share the x axis
with X as one this way as we zoom in and
do kind of as we interact with these
charts they share the same x axis just a
nice convenient way to do that okay so
we have our axes now we want to plot on
those axes so we're gonna say a x1 dot
plot and we are going to plot the time
act your seas and then we are going to
label this as AK and then we're going to
X 1 dot pull plots and actually it's
gonna be very similar so I'm just gonna
copy pasta x and then we want to graph
Val X so they'll be on the exact same
chart you'll see that in a moment
Val AK and that way we can very easily
compare them and see as they begin to
trend apart because that is your big red
flag and then a X 1 dot legend and we'll
set this to location 2 there's various
locations I just know location 2 will be
out of the way if everything goes
correctly if it's in the way it means
things went wrong anyways and it doesn't
matter you'll see what I mean
and then ax dos dot plot and I kind of
want to copy and paste it's gonna be a
lot of editing but let's do it so it's a
X 2 X 2 X 2 and then it is time it's
always times but then here we want to
say was it losses losses yes losses and
Val loss this is right is that right Val
losses yes and then here we want to say
loss and then Val offs ok so those are
the things that we want to graph we will
run APL t dot show show me the money ok
cool so now you can kind of see first of
all there's a couple of things we'd like
to do right the gate is like and like
smooth these graphs a bit this does
bother me but I also want this video to
be less than 5 hours long so I can't do
everything but anyways you can see like
as i zoom in to a specific spot both of
these graphs updated at the same time
there's various things I'd like to fix
like you know alignments and stuff but
anyway it's pretty cool because you
could do that you can click so I did
that by clicking on this magnifying
glass you can click on this button kind
of drag around and stuff but for the
most part this looks pretty good
what I want to show you
so for example you can kind of see if we
applied some sort of moving average
which would be so much easier in pandas
the next time we do a chart like this
I'm just gonna use pandas but try to
keep things as simple as possible but
these look pretty tightly coupled I mean
they are pretty close to one another but
you can see VALIC is at least slightly
lower than accuracy but this is all to
be very very expected we can also see
that validation loss so this is your
out-of-sample loss is slightly higher
loss again that's to be expected but
everything's kind of trending together
it looks pretty good this tells me I can
keep training this model like these are
all kind of going together pretty well
it is when accuracy validation accuracy
and accuracy start to diverge that we
have a problem and usually actually the
losses will diverge before the accuracy
so if you really want to stop at the
perfect point you watch loss instead so
what I've done is I moved in a log file
that contains a 38 box example where are
you
yes model 30 box log so what I'm gonna
do is just to show you guys so we don't
have to wait 30 minutes I'm gonna I'm
gonna edit or I'm gonna read that file
and the name is this time stamp cool so
this will be a quick example you can run
this on your own if you'd like but I
just want to show you guys this is 30
epochs and it turns out this is actually
at the point where they start to diverge
it is about e8 epochs that's why I had
eight as the initial number there but
this is thirty epochs so as you can see
just make this nice and big and by the
way if you if you graph in ipython
notebook you just can't interact with
the with the actual graph so that's why
I'm doing it here so we can actually
interact with it just as some basic
information to a matplotlib generally I
tend to go by about 40,000 plots or you
points on a graph after about 40,000
starts to lag depending on what CPU
you're running you might need to do a
different number again with pandas you
could just resample so yeah well you'll
use pandas later but anyway you can see
here how accuracy continues to go up and
we've even got many batches that have a
perfect 1.0 you know so 100% accuracy
but after about 80% accuracy we can see
that validation accuracy while while it
doesn't actually get that much worse it
just stops improving it's just never
improving again and we can see here that
loss kind of similar it fell fell fell
but then actually it starts to trend
back up so it would probably be the case
that as if we continued to Train we
would pricey validation accuracy fall
and that in this is just a perfect
example of over fitment happening and
you can just you can see it so well
because it's coming up up up up up up up
and then and then even the deviations
here are getting smaller and smaller
like this model is just learning to fit
and just fit the input data so it's just
kind of it's cool because that's what
neural networks do there's so many
parameters that can be tweaked and
there's there's just so many variables
that can be tweaked that you really can
just memorize the data so just keep that
in mind as you go forward and just
remember just watch the divergence of
losses and accuracies and usually you
can pay get pretty quick and anyway so
you'd really probably want to stop
training the model around this point
that's basically the end so I think
that's all I really want to talk about
for now but yep that's how you can
analyze your models a lot much ado about
a pretty basic graph in my opinion but
we actually made a lot of different
little itty-bitty changes and hopefully
you've kind of you can see now what
happens when you train a model out way
too long it looks really great on your
in sample data but on any out-of-sample
real data it has not improved and again
if you continued I imagine just looking
at loss getting worse here
bow loss because again in
applause is only improving it's only
continuing to drop and we've even got
some zeros again because it's it's
learning to predict perfectly on in
sample data which is bad so because we
want the mock we want the neural network
to generalize not memorize okay so
that's it I hope you guys enjoyed if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
if you want to support me the channel
videos like this click on that beautiful
beautiful blue join button help support
me in the channel if you click on that
you get early access to videos just like
this one special rank in the discord a
little logo by your name in the comments
and stuff like that so that's it I will
see you guys in the next video where we
will be hopefully diving into some sort
of project I haven't fully decided I've
kind of tested out a few different
things it's very difficult to figure out
what I want to go with for a project
here such I'm trying to keep it basic
but I'm trying to not do the same stuff
I've always done I want to do other
things so we'll see we'll see so I
haven't decide what it is but I'll see
you in the next video where we're
hopefully doing something interesting
until next time